i've said it before if you hate cops
just
because they're cops then uh feel free
to call a criminal
call a meth head the next time you get
in trouble
sounds good does anybody have hunter's
number
[Applause]
you know every morning i try to find a
story that gets me out of bed
something that shouts gut fell take off
the handcuffs put down the cool whip
write about this
so i try to look for stuff that other
media giants ignore and i try not to
wake up jesse
i like what the news denies because that
is where the truth lies
take this brawl at the miami
international airport it's simply
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
would it hurt to hold your phone
horizontally coppola
of course it's all on video and like a
rash i got on spring break
it's gone viral it's already beaten the
oscars in the ratings
which is like beating ted bundy and
friend requests
kind of easy it happened on concourse d
gate 12.
i'd say it's a stone's throw from
starbucks but i don't condone violence
apparently and allegedly which will be
popular children's names next year
passengers were waiting for their
chicago flight when one group was
told there were just three standby seats
and they were a party of four
obviously their first mistake flying to
chicago
unless you're a drug mule with three
pounds of coke in your anus
you won't stand a chance
word always gets a laugh rob an argument
an argument developed with the agent who
then asked another group if they'd like
to fly instead of the four who didn't
want to split up
naturally that led to both groups
exchanging pleasantries
but what began as a measured mutually
respectful give and take degenerated
into a more impassioned exchange as
conflicting points of view were
presented
and in some cases rejected and like an
anti-cop speech at the oscars it just
keeps going and going
it's like being on hold with american
airlines
if this is happening before you board
how are they going to share an armrest
on the bright side usually you have to
wait until you're at baggage claim for
something like this
not that these are real fighters they
look like they escaped from a 90s repeat
of the jerry springer show
it's fun to watch but then like after
eating the spirit airlines clam plate
you feel really sick and you think
maybe this is it is this a kind of
if this is a kind of thing that can
happen in an airport
especially during pre-boarding when
children traveling alone and adults who
need a little more time
are invited to board why are we
surprised when it happens in our streets
this isn't outside of portland city hall
this is in an airport
mere minutes away from any number of
fine gentlemen's clubs
and no id pawn shops cat we're your
granddad
might be if he wasn't sequestered in a
basement watching infomercials for
garlic hiding from a disease he's
already vaccinated for
no wonder so many people think violence
is an okay method to achieve political
goals
they're willing to use it for airline
seats we are watching generations not in
decline but completely disconnected from
agreed upon standards
of decency i know every older generation
says this about the young kids but this
feels kind of worse
it's about the loss of human interaction
the ability to reason and cooperate
which is the mark of success the ability
to see a problem through and figure out
how to work toward a mutually beneficial
outcome that doesn't include
kicking someone in the head that
behavior will
earn you no upgrades at delta or in life
but it's what successful people learn
when they're young impulse control
cooperation hopefully from their parents
or mentors or a suitable role model like
greg gutfeld
without that you don't have a future
you're at the bottom and your life goes
down the
downhill from there well unless you're
alec baldwin then you just look for
someone to blame
for that hill being there when i look at
all this i wonder why no one intervened
instead the brawl just multiplied
which presented witnesses in their
smartphones with a moral dilemma which
fight do you film
the one where three guys are attempting
to beat a fourth guy to death or the
more evenly matched fight between the
other four guys
choose the wrong one it may may not go
viral and then how are you supposed to
get
self-esteem by earning the respect of
your family and peers
we're a nation of ken burns's minus the
sugar bowl haircut
we're not just witnessing the decline of
western civilization we're taping it and
why not that's far easier than reversing
it
meanwhile people mostly stand around
watching why intervene
that's not their job you know cops do
that sort of thing what a bunch of
suckers
and then we blame them and really why
intervene you might end up like a cop
who prevents a stabbing
because you're the bad guy trying to
stop bad things from happening
finally security did arrive hooray but
no wonder the lockdown holds so much
appeal for people with steady paychecks
i'm not afraid breaking lockdown rules
because i might get coveted i'm afraid
to because
i might get stabbed while pre-boarding
so the big lesson
if you must travel just remember to do
so in groups of
three or fewer or take greyhound it has
a higher class clientele
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
in college he majored in saying the
quiet part out loud
my fellow co-hosts on the five at waters
world host jose walters everybody
he's so libertarian he owns the rights
to what and ever
co-host of the fifth bomb podcast
camille foster
he's done more screenwriting than a
graffiti artist trapped in a mosquito
tent
tv writer and producer rob long
and she never cries over spilt milk it's
not like there's any booze in it
host of sicily counter fox station cat
tim
welcome to the show jesse thank you i
just want to congratulate you greg no
one
ever thought you'd make it this far and
it's an honor to be on a show with an
exclamation point behind it
like other great shows such as alvin and
the chipmunks
scooby dooby doo where are you and
i'm a celebrity get me out of here
which by the way i'm not feeling right
now
i i saw that one coming you did you know
what i want to congratulate your
assistant johnny for coming up with
those
are you saying you don't think i do my
own research
i'm saying we all know that okay that is
not fake news
so any thoughts are you you're probably
upset that i got that tape before you
got it
we'll be using it on waters world this
weekend yes
there's actually better tape but we
couldn't get it well i'll get it by the
time waters world tapes
[Laughter]
when i saw this i thought that's why
americans don't lose wars
because we're ready to brawl over a
standby seat out of miami
imagine if they came for new jersey
it'd be a bloodbath and gutfeld where is
the security when i go
into an airport my mother sets off an
alarm with her fake hip and
security descends on her like a
terrorist yes
where is everybody yeah it you know you
used to have tough guys
break up fights you get a few licks in
and then
you go break it up now all the tough
guys just tape it and then
sell it to tmz that is true because if
you get involved you get cancelled
right and you don't want that no no but
i do know you did this video for one
reason why
to show how dangerous it is to fly
commercial so when you renegotiate your
next contract
you fly private
i'm on to you he's on to me that is the
right insight you know camille i was
when i was watching that i
it's like whatever happened to fair
fights like if they were like if they
each one paired off i would be okay with
that but there was three on one here
you know it was like a lot of people
kicking people when they're down yeah
you don't ever do that no i only do that
anonymously
i didn't know if you were doing a thing
when you said fair fights
there um i cannot imagine actually let
me start here
the very best thing about the pandemic
to the extent there could be a best
thing about it was that the airports
were completely empty
and had all of these opportunities to
ride on planes
fly in first class of course never coach
because people like that are the ones in
coach causing trouble
but i had all these opportunities to fly
on the plane by myself
yeah only me and now we're getting back
to normal and there are
complete utter brawls chaos yeah in the
standby line well but no but the
restaurants are still only at 50
capacity so there's nothing to do so
they got to do that people got to do
this so this is what we have to look
forward to yeah they're at a low
standard
for behavior libertarians all i'm saying
is that that guy that did get beat up he
decided not to press
charges he's probably like that punch
hurt but i feel alive again
that's the weirdest thing i will say
this rob i
remember when i had that kind of energy
i got exhausted just following the
action
did you look at it and go wow you can
barely move you know from the chair
i i'm just mesmerized by by the pants
right now um no look i think
what i think what you said your
monologue was maybe the dumbest thing
i've ever heard you say
what about this guy
what about this isn't the greatest thing
we've seen in a year and a half
that's normal this stuff happened
pre-coded
all the time and this is normal people
on standby
fighting and going crazy and like and
and then the this is fantastic
it's over we're fighting in airports
again
we're back man we're back this made me
so happy
i'm like more
would you uh rob would you have
intervened should you
you know what are you kidding at that
point i'm at the tgi fridays
like two-thirds of the way through the
margaritas like
the
do you ever go for the larger beverage
like when they offer you an extra shot
oh yeah i mean they don't offer it to me
i order it ahead of time
you can't it's the polite reply yeah it
would be rude to send the shot back
oh my god i i start with this is all
going to be super size
yes also did they not have masks on
that's where i am
that's where i have the real problem
that was in miami by the way i just came
back from miami
cove it didn't happen in my life no one
stopped
no although i was there on fourth of
july and they did close down the beaches
which was
ridiculous that was because you were in
a speedo
actually it's a sequin song